servus leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir schauen uns mal
kurz jungen gummi auf dem boden box im
hintergrund sieht aus wie ein kampfsport
jim ich bin jetzt hier in berlin im
spitfire german das bildschirm ist das
zuhause von aristo lu ist das hier
könnte man hier
ich habe ich mit aristo verabredet ich
bin in berlin deswegen wir nutzen die
zeit machen training zusammen vielleicht
noch ein kleines spannung hinten raus
und kleinen soweit ich ziehe mich jetzt
mal los der macht auch youtube dann
schaut man die beschreibung heute die
erste übung des heutigen tages 3
vor allem hier besser über das sehen
können aber dass es ein springseil mit
stahl sehr heiß wäre das mit schwung
gegen die füße bekommen kalte füße auch
direkt abschneiden
aber es ist wichtig weil im kampfsport
ich die hüfte einer unserer stärksten
waffen und da kommt die meiste kraft und
er muss man noch locker und beweglichen
dürfte sehr steif ist ja nicht so viel
kraft umsetzen wie sie mal locker nach
vorne schlagen
wichtig ist immer la cruz immer nach
oben ein bisschen für seite bewegen
dennoch wenn wir kämpfen würde wenn ich
meine deckung habe die durch manndeckung
schön auf die nase oder kind und dann
ist es oftmals vorbei oder der blüte
erstmalig teil nummer zwei ich habe mir
als trainer machen kick backs mit rock
es war schön mit euch leute main kanal
dmax
normal
wichtig ist logik immer mit shimano 2
ja
märz
ich habe 40 sekunden in dem wir den
gegner jetzt unter feuer
jetzt wird geackert
so arbeitet man dass das training so und
nicht anders fokus und wenn jetzt
deutsch
na ja das ist unser ziel er zeigt mit
sidekicks durch
machen wir sparen business spielen mal
gucken wo fehler sind bei den anderen
zeiten deckung hoch wie geht sich um die
härte sondern um die technik
bekanntmachen
wir haben ein bisschen gespielt ja ich
wusste wie ich ausweichen kann was ich
machen kann
treffer klickt man immer ob die gänge
anfängen oder sonstwas treffer kriegt
man immer das heißt nicht wo ich bin
jetzt profi in der öffentlichkeit
die frage ist wie stecke ich die treffer
weg wie konnte wie bewege ich mich um
bleibe ich stehen zu dürfen
sehr geil hat mir spaß gemacht mit ihm
zu trainieren der junge war die nummer 1
in frankfurt unbedingt abchecken wenn ja
jemand sehen wollte richtig kämpfen kann
dann wirst du schon soweit reingemacht
gut grund